you got the mri results but i see over
there with whiskey and popping pills
yeah you got a little cold you got a
little cold yeah is it good or bad no so
they they did tell me that for a fact uh
i do have a pinched nerve
yeah and he said he said he's been doing
this for like over 35 years so he's like
i'm gonna be honest with you
you're probably gonna need surgery
so
i gotta figure out my opinion yeah so
i'm i'm getting referred from him to
another osteo
specialist like a spine doctor yeah but
we're gonna go over huh is it his butt
he recommended him
i don't know if he he's just you know he
he's asking for the authorization who
could help you you said that yeah
so there's like a c7 c6 and there's a
nerve in between it yeah and it's i
guess on my neck on this side it's like
deteriorating more oh wow this happens a
lot it just naturally just happens to
some people
so it wasn't anything specific it's not
a bulging disc herniated it you do have
a herniated yeah yeah so it is it's it's
hitting that nerve yeah
my best friends is going through the
same thing he's my same age he works on
computers a lot too so that's always
bending down yeah somehow with your
posture yeah that's true but you you
started getting hurt right now yeah but
it might have been like ready to go and
then all right you know it might just
might be a combination no i think if if
it turns that means it's already been
you know deteriorating for a while it's
not going to be like
smashed
so i'm going to probably just go i'm
asking for an injection first and then
try to just work out get better i would
avoid that yeah the worst case i'll get
the surgery why was is the surgery just
wild or anytime you just never want to
do surgery especially on your phone i
don't want to go under either it's scary
dude what's this doctor's name
i don't know kevorkian feel good
what kind of name is that that's my
neurologist that's persian persian he's
he's 70 something years old he's been
doing this forever
and they gave me these nerve tests too
where they stick needles in you you move
your arm down no he moved so he found
out which nerve it was it's the seventh
nerve and he's like that's the one
that's in your c7
did he did he give you anything any
painkillers zero yeah you have no
painkillers zero painkillers that's what
i'm taking tylenol
but
all that stuff helps right it definitely
helps with the alcohol which sucks i
don't
i don't advise that for anyone because
it's bad for your body
no i have nothing all the years of
training you don't have any pain you
said you had neck issues all right for a
camp you're the only guy i've ever met
who played football has never had a knee
operation i know that's [ __ ] cool
don't you have that foot thing no man
that was when i was fighting i'm fine
now oh and that was only because he was
running so much on the bad shoes
yeah
it makes such a [ __ ] difference nine
days i mean those [ __ ] old boots
that's why they they're in these boots
so that's why we're kicking coal what's
wrong with the frog well i look taller
in these they make me two inches taller
these have these have lifts so i'm 5 11
as you know maybe a little bit taller
than that we'll give you five eleven
let's give me five eleven six foot in
those days we figured it out at least
six feet indeed oh you guys should
rejoice i started squid games
what are your thoughts so far yeah what
are your thoughts it's good
where where are you good
careful i'm on episode i just i'm i'll
uh start five tonight okay oh when i get
rolling
i'm in okay you're in it's good it's
really good yeah why are you saying it
though i know right now i can't tell you
it's not i know it's it's a really like
me and my girl love it like we're like
squid games like
i'll tell you this hold on hold on
there's a butt it's good it's good
yeah now for you to say he's been on
game of thrones can i get a little bit
more game of thrones you're not done yet
though
i don't need i don't know no he did yeah
i i know why we talk about game of
thrones
for the next 30 years yeah game of
thrones games we will forget about in
tune well game of thrones
is now game of thrones is epic this is
uh this is
a different this is gimmick it's
gimmicky it's like oh i'm seeing it it's
good dude the way it's shot yeah
the way it's shot acting oh my god and
the acting now i'm going to give you
this you know what you're watching
is this race or not right some of them i
can't stand the way they talk
and it's not korean like are you doing
dubs or yeah
but them talking korean like some of the
creating koreans beautiful and then
someone i'm like dude no those
characters are supposed to be annoying
oh my gosh like a lady
yeah like who [ __ ] it with the dragon
tattoo hey spoiler alert but i'm sure
you're not long enough
by the way episode six i'm gonna go
[Applause]
why is she yelling like they're so good
at [ __ ] faces and yeah the way they
talk that they pick they're such
a [ __ ] great i like that she keeps
calling them babe
now they're acting as as good as it gets
i think yeah but but episode six wow
episode six is very i forget which one
is uh
oh marbles
yeah oh yeah you can't tell them yeah
that's heavy yeah that [ __ ] is heavy
well that's it that is that main
character is a loser he drives me nuts
get your [ __ ] down
shitty dad
shitty dad it's just like this loser
i'll tell you what if i was picking
teams i sure as [ __ ] when pig can't
match look at him and then when he's
throwing one though he's not hey
just wait
hey you know what would be though yeah
it would be dope if they uh remake the
american version and matt damon's in it
you can be the old guy
and i'll be the guy with the dragon
tattoo
you're the old guy i know
you take the pass
no this is his pants no i'm you're the
old guy when we when i'm killing people
at night when y'all go to sleep yeah
because i'm trying to get the number
count down and i'm killing people you're
the old guy pisses his pants gets on top
of the shed and goes stop
that's you that's me you're the old guy
that's how we're going to do it hey
that's how we're doing
you know your cat says that in this
right no way dude if there's a squid
game you know you're that i'm guy you
know who i am chin's the genius i'm the
guy who wins cat's the the
that one girl is so pretty to me
because they have that nasty one having
sex together i'm like oh my god pretty
oh she her face is gorgeous she was a
model prior to squid game yeah and then
this is the first one
hey you wait till six and seven oh she
gets
she gets so naked dude
oh the dragon tells you that gets with
her i'm not telling you yeah no you get
you got to watch it you got to watch it
you got to watch it hey i'll tell you
what though show stresses me out yeah
yeah it's so stressful it's [ __ ]
stressful i i think there's no rhyme or
reason
absolutely i didn't breathe well say
that's a little slow because they get
out right and they gotta go back in yeah
one and three the third episode i like i
didn't breathe yeah yeah it's and and i
didn't breathe i was texting kat and
steven i'm like i'm so stressed now that
guy tried to get that show made for 10
years and nobody that's what's so
[ __ ] crazy
what's crazy you see he came out and
goes you know it's the biggest streaming
show on netflix ever
uh i'm not really making much money yeah
because off of the original contract
they did yeah because remember they
didn't think it was gonna be a hit so it
cost 9 million produced so like right
here's your check it's not a lot he's
like like i'm not balling
oh no
he says he's home he's going to be he's
michael got it you want [ __ ] uh squid
game two two yeah yeah daddy pay up i'm
the only one who can shoot it like
that's a tall order though right how is
he going to you got to write something
just it's good i do the same thing games
stress i don't know no the way the way
season one ends
don't tell me i'm not telling you but
dude i'm already talking about brian
that's already
enough how's that enough i said wait
when
i'll be done with it by far by monday
tell me
i wasn't gonna say anything yeah but we
like you the way that dude i would have
gotten the plane the way it ends
i didn't see any of that my daughter's
this way my daughter's like she's only
in episode six and yeah you even say
well i got she's like yeah yeah i'm like
all right all right that's right social
media try spoiling online i see nah you
know what my son did he's 10 years old
he he watches youtube and finds out what
happens he watches
the [ __ ] kid then he goes like this
i'm going to ruin it i'm like you ruin
it i'll kill you
well he's a kid so he's just
what i like to do
that's interesting what i like to do
though is uh after i like i get done
with the
midnight mass or like yellowstone or
even game of thrones i'll go back and
there's like podcasts there's youtubers
i will watch all of those i get so into
it they have them on squigging oh yes
do they we should stop
johnny come lately here right you said
this is gonna happen it's good if you
watch anything that's related to squid
game on youtube on the videos they're
like in the millions anyone talking
about in the millions yeah that's how
huge this thing is we should talk about
squid games
you know who's the best looking person
in the entire thing if you guys remember
in the first episode the guy playing
that game
yeah yeah oh that guy oh my god
who is this i would ruin my life the guy
the first game brian
no a little no i know but i don't want
the gigi and stuff i don't know oh yeah
he's a good looking guy
all right
well there's his face my cat was
mentioning i was telling you guys to
watch that movie put calvin klein
gong
they were showing him and i i i went to
my girl
no no no i i need you guys to see this
i'm well aware i know a good looking
creature oh he's a good-looking guy he's
built like a brick [ __ ] house he's got a
good body
but when he's in a suit on it and i told
my like they're playing that game
because i was it is what it is no matter
what ethnicist it is i told my dog hey
is everybody ugly in this [ __ ] show
yeah and she's like yeah so far until
that dime piece girl showed up but then
when he showed up i go i paused it yeah
and my girl goes why are you pausing and
go is he distractingly good looking and
she goes why'd i go he is gorgeous she
goes you're weird i go i need you to
accept that that guy's going just she
goes he's all right are you out of your
mind i don't think she's a good looking
guy no but she was like he's good
looking yeah yeah he's good looking guys
they've been a [ __ ] boy on these
pictures
he's playing that slap game yeah
obviously this boy is fine yeah i like i
just like you know
you should you already read it but
that's that girl
if you're [ __ ] i wouldn't be
surprised and i would go like this if i
walked by a window and i saw you having
sex with like a red light district and
if you were really giving it to him and
you were face to face his legs were in
the air and that's how you would do it
and i would go like this no i'd be i'd
be a power button
oh yeah no i don't want to disrespect
them okay maybe but i mean i think i
would battle eat and then pass
super racist and that's not what korean
people do that is not racist that's like
shaking your hands okay
but you know what the bowel is like
yeah
you know the difference between uh when
uh in asian culture when they bow when
the british bow to the to the queen you
know the difference what's the
difference queen like this just head if
you're uh ben at the waist is
disrespectful okay i didn't know that
yeah you know i thank you that's the
lower you bow the more so if you are if
you have your martial arts teacher and
he's your mother dude with him you go
very low dude you would go right lower
shows respect with him i'd go
all the way down and you would stay down
try and suck my own dick all the way i
get so loud try and suck my underwear
but anyway if you were [ __ ] him i
would go like this and i've known you a
long time you're a straight guy but if i
saw that i would walk by and i'd go like
this make sense i'd go hmm and i just
keep walking and i'd never say anything
to you it'd be fine i just would be like
this i would rather she's so i like her
so much she is such a badass look at her
she uh ended up at i think like 20
something million instagram instagram
followers overnight or some [ __ ] yeah
really
like 20 something within a month what
the ig look like she's such a good
actress she's also special but she's
really young right oh no 27 27 no that's
actually older for whoa
damn look at her oh my god she even has
drake's thirst for
drake tried to holler drake is uh yeah
she's still on the inside she's on the
thinner side
you know you know what my style is fine
yeah yeah all right
she's also talented i would love her
like she looks tall
she's too tall for a b
she's special
she's so good in that no she's special
and then they gotta team up because
they're all killing each other at night
dude i would just protect her yeah you
would though i just like stayed behind
me the whole time
what's her name i was really hoping she
was in the sex scene
yeah
hey only 2.000
look at that smile sorry oh she's so
pretty i just love the koreans are
having their day man yeah remember the
academy award they won parasite my my
one of the if not the most influential
person in my life was
my korean taekwondo teacher yeah take it
easy
take it easy it's really true yeah he
changed my life oh well don't take that
picture but that's fine
someone said mommy mommy mommy i don't
know why they're saying that why they
say oh that's a tick tock thing where
you see a hot woman and you call her
mommy like oh i like that are they doing
daddy daddy daddy there's a flip of it
but it's mainly for women yeah yeah
mommy mommy mommy yeah like mommy all
right mommy yeah show's good though man
yeah i'm glad you like it in squid games
i gotta see midnight mass hate seeing
that yet i hate seeing it hey b you know
when you watch lebron james play
basketball do you ever go man i wonder
what makes him sleep
that's right what makes him sleep
because that's his superpower okay
that's how he scores so many points i
didn't know that yep he gets good rest
and you know why he uses calm the number
one app for sleep meditation used it and
i do use it and i have it on my phone
and lebron teamed up with calm to help
you activate the power of sleep yeah
because hey do you want to be like
lebron you want mental fitness and if
you don't have sleep you don't get sleep
you your mental fitness is not where it
belongs that's where calm comes
on
what your mind is like and any other
muscle in your body you don't have to be
a world champion to learn how to train
it that's where calm helps you out man
they help train your brain to sleep
better reduce your stress perform at
your best just like the king they have
meditation they have stories you can
actually listen to somebody speak you
have rain you have all different kinds
of sounds my my girl uses it every
single night to sleep yes because you've
got ron whispering in her hair well that
i won't allow i'm just not going to
allow it going he's too sexy
i'm better than george i keep him i keep
him for myself now you're careful don't
say if he says i don't think he's better
if he says i'm better than you then i
get upset and then i get upset and i
will be too and then i can't sleep i'll
be enraged
so if you head to calm.com fighter for
limit time you get 40 off a calm premium
subscription again for limited time the
listeners and viewers
of firing the kid can join lebron and
using calm and get 40 off a discount all
right calm for freedom subscription
oh my god sleep stories meditations oh
my god when you're ready for all the
challenges as life throws your way it's
very hard to fall asleep limited time
com.com fighter
you'll see 267 action is live in abu
dhabi and we have a fight campaign this
saturday 11 a.m pacific but listen watch
it with us all right watch it with us
and make bank bro with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports band
partner of the ufc and man do they have
a deal for the new customers you can bet
just five dollars on either fighter in
the main event to win all right if your
guy wins you win 200 in free bets all
right so will the champion john win or
will glover texara beat him up find out
bet on it bet just five dollars on ufc
267 main event win 200 bucks and free
bets if your fighter wins draftkings is
safe secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter throw
just five dollars on the main event of
ufc 267 and win 200 in free bets if your
fighter wins that's code fighter this
saturday at draftking sportsbook
official sports betting partner the ufc
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit one dollar
wager required one per customer
restriction supply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1 800 gambler any movies i should
catch
[ __ ] i don't see i don't really [ __ ]
with movies dude i yeah i i can't think
of it i i just want do you like like
foreign stuff a lot or just nah yeah i
do because we j i can't think of the
[ __ ] name right now it's i think it's
called richie it's about this rapper in
amsterdam
[Music]
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do you a song
we're out
giving it to rapper yeah he's out
it's rich i was i was so richie yeah
karen
uh it's it's basically about a rapper he
pretends to be like basically it's like
690 but tends to be like hood and street
and everything and one day after a show
he someone robs him and like they like
film him like like they have like a
bunch of knives pointed at me he's like
crying and his career starts to plummet
because they see that he's a fake he's a
fraud so the whole movie it's like very
like like it made me like my anxiety
through the roof because the entire time
he's like trying everything he does to
try and build his uh reputation back up
yeah they do something that brings his
reputation back down so like the entire
movie it's a battle between that is it
produced by takashi 6'9 it's not it's
way better than his career
you'll check it out it's it was honestly
it took me about as far as it was yeah
richie what'd you find it on
um i think it was netflix it was really
good
i saw not being recorded i watched a
movie from the 90s uh i'm sorry from
2008
it was
so bad what was it it was with uh ashton
kutcher
uh good i'm sure oh and bernie mac he's
not just
friends where's my car no it's called
what happens in vegas oh cameron diaz
the worst movie i've ever [ __ ] said
the fun one
it's so bad and the premise so you
watched it
my girl was watching i was like and i
kept going so this is the worst [ __ ]
i've ever seen they they both won a
thing in vegas but he gave her the the
quarter or no she gave him the quarter
and he brings the thing then they got to
share it yeah then in order to split it
they got to get married and then they
hate each other which is fun and then oh
super wrong
i'm sure he's a good guy and i know he's
smart with tech he he's just not a good
actor he's it he's actually seen steve
jobs
no oh he's good in that i'm sure he's
not good you don't think he's a good
actor no i think he's actually in that
movie
he's so bad that it it's it's offensive
and i'm sorry i i've never i don't
criticize people you've never seen do
what i don't like
he seems like a great guy i just think
he was he knows he was terrible in that
he has to know and zach galifianakis was
in it i'm sure zach was like what am i
doing here
i like cameron diaz no matter what but
it was terrible but you were interacting
in it no i didn't like her acting i
thought it was terrible just a terrible
movie i thought everybody was terrible
and the movie was terrible you know
i'm not gonna it's not gonna win any
awards but the past time yeah yeah last
time i'd rather it's like bad teacher
i'll go to the test yes or whatever
that's good oh that looks good
that's just pretty bad i like ass i
think i think steve jobs to me was
better than uh fast bender i like him
and steve jobs better than fassbender
fastband is a beast yeah he is just a
bad script i thought
yeah
oh i love that movie one of my favorites
a lot like steve yeah they did a good
job
yeah he was great in that
look at that is that really steve jobs
that's him wow big dick energy
yeah he was brilliant
complete [ __ ] apparently
yeah it there's cancer that got him
right
pancreatic satan you know he had a type
of pancreatic cancer that was curable it
wasn't the other the one there are two
types one kills you right away this one
was actually curable but tell him why he
died brian he refused to [ __ ]
do eastern medicine and refuse to take
the real [ __ ] in america yeah and the
doctor's like we can save your life this
is
they said he would have survived like
another like 15 20 years but he was like
nah i'm gonna eat these
goji berries or whatever ginseng pills
and do acupuncture meanwhile they're
like cancer was like this is hilarious
you're going to die and that's what it
is what i always say about this is why i
always say about eastern medicine has
has always said it has its value you've
always said it at 80 in the 80s i
watched eight nights i watched people
die of aids i watched it personally with
my own eyes i knew people who died it
was awful i watched them die slowly and
with no dignity it was a horrible
disease
and all of them tried everything they
went to china they tried everything and
then along came something called produce
inhibitors which are westernized science
and they
that saved everybody's life that's
that's why there's magic johnson's still
alive still yeah that's interesting with
him his whole conspiracy theory with
that anyway is it really oh yeah but did
you see uh
aids is still popping man it's not like
we solved that problem is it still
broken not not in north america but in
in uh in the world aids kills tons of
people so what the chin bring up how
people die from age i don't know about
that because i do yeah well aids
that's a real bad problem still
ages had to compromise itself so often
hey i bet you more people die from aids
and coven oh i believe that i believe
you
you see something though
almost one million each year some
countries the leading cause of death wow
it's one of the worst most fatal
infectious diseases
particularly across the south africa
told you
everyone any other brain busters brian
so now when you get hiv they will tell
you that you're going to die from
something else because the viruses have
compromised itself so often and we have
pills where it just keeps it at bay but
access if you're hiv like obviously
there's hiv positive and then there's
full blood hiv positive you see those
commercials yeah of mainly you know gay
guys they're like you know i took one
pill and i still you know do my thing
that's it it'll keep it in you look like
that
hey god damn he said i still do one
thing and and they get it to a point
where it's undetectable in your blood so
yeah you can have sex even without a cop
yeah oh yeah oh dude you're a raw dog
yeah with this
pill you were talking sure roll the dice
as soon as you're on the pitch but i
remember when it was just a death
sentence i watched it yeah i watched it
man
it was not good you ever seen
philadelphia yeah uh no with tom hanks
and denzel yeah i've never seen her
they couldn't keep food down antonio
banderas yeah and you get those weird
spots on your face you can't keep food
down you get parasites it's horrible man
i went to college with a kid who uh got
it and doing butt stuff yeah he was
always very very dangerous gang man yeah
it is but he died it was awful man it
was [ __ ] awful yeah but thank you to
science thank you to science and he's
well thank me for educating me on how
deadly it still is brian i know a guy
who sold all his stuff he sold all his
stuff i mean literally all the stuff he
goes he had you know a couple months and
produce inhibitors came in and they
[ __ ] lit knife still alive is this
the plot of dallas club no i oh i don't
know if that i didn't see that
is that what it is yeah sold all this
[ __ ]
yeah it is i was in acting class with
him so holy [ __ ] was gonna die
it starts with his best friend's
transgender
yeah
hey man
this is the plot of dallas buyers i took
an acting class in texas
and then he [ __ ] he had he was like i
sold all my [ __ ] and then he that was
his problem but he lived he's still
alive that's awesome which one does
charles sheen have doesn't he have any
hiv hiv hiv is hiv is the virus that
causes aids is different full-blown age
like magic johnson has hiv and charlie
sheen has human acquired i thought i
thought magic john's had aids he's hiv
positive no they're both hiv positive
they wouldn't be alive if they had that
yeah that's why once aids takes over
there's nothing we can do yeah hiv if
you catch it you're cause i was
surprised because charlie sheen's like
all then again it's probably all the
drug like yeah his from john's needles
probably well
magic johnson's still
better what that's rumors yeah i mean
rumors i think that i didn't even
mention that wasn't there some kind of
uh that hooked up with a dude some kind
of a man who was dressed like a woman
and then there was something oh my gosh
i don't know
i don't know maybe he was shooting up
he's doing a lot of drugs doing a lot of
blow and a lot of it is very rare for a
straight now see if i'm right
yep there's that there's
it's very rare that a straight man dies
of aids it's almost it's almost it's
unheard of very rare yeah there's
usually some unless it's africa so the
reason enough in africa for sure or
unless they're drug users and the reason
in africa is because that part of the
world didn't get the bubonic plague if
you suffered from the bubonic plague you
have a built-in resistance to aids you
have a genetic mutation that makes you
resistant and the only way to get it if
you're a straight guy is to get it
pushed into your body into your system
that's why intravenous drug users and if
you get [ __ ] through your butt yeah
you see a needle blood transfusion or
getting in the butt chin bring up a
percentage of uh
uh straight
i tried straight males
with a stroke
statistic it's just for hiv.gov let's
see my acting teacher was gay
approximately 1.2 people in the u.s have
hiv about 13 of them didn't know didn't
know it
um
so hiv continues uh to impact certain
populations particularly racial ethnic
ethnic minorities gay bisexual and other
men who have sex with men
yeah yeah so so so um
back in the day you used to get what's
called carposi sarcoma so you'd be to my
my my acting teacher had a young man a
neighbor who was gay and young kid
and [ __ ] he's talking to him in the
in the hallway of his apartment and he
goes
he just sees a tiny little purple
splotch
and he goes come here what is that and
he sees it and that was the beginning of
his he realized he [ __ ] had aids he
had this rare skin cancer that only very
old men of middle east
mediterranean descent get very rarely
and
aids patients would get intrinsic
heterosexual contact
male to male is 81
yeah in 2018
yeah i don't believe the hetero contact
it's just not this the science doesn't i
i don't buy that
i just don't i mean i've looked at
yeah it's interesting yeah maybe maybe
if you include africa there yeah yeah no
that's u.s i think
i i don't know that's what got freddie
mercury
right yep freddie mercury
he got it when we had no no cure for
anything
ah damn it affects a lot of african
americans yes 40 of it yes and that's
another reason because if you're of
african-american descent if you're an
african descent you don't have the same
immunity as someone of of european
descent but brian i i like it but uh
this is uh u.s stats
so that's 40 of african-americans
the heterosexual men like the 10 could
be like people in jail i think maybe
could be that something
that could be a thing i don't know i
also have a lot of gay black dudes out
there yeah
yeah
yeah that's interesting it's interesting
no one really talks about aids anymore
no
well you and i talking about the fact
that in california now
you can say that you're a woman and you
get put in a man you you a man gets put
in a
woman's prison you know do you know that
no what you and i weren't talking about
so so they were handing out condoms
so you're you're a guy you're a guy and
you go i'm i'm a woman i identify as a
woman and they were putting them into
there there are men right now who
identify as women in jail in california
in female prisons type move if you're a
guy
very tight you're surrounded by here's
the thing some of the women are getting
pregnant you understand
yeah and now they're trying to there's
this thing well let's hand out condoms
very interesting so you can go in there
full dick and balls
but if you
that's a that and they just now you say
you're a woman i don't know the details
but this is what it's probably being
talking you know what though it's
probably not a huge problem though you
know what's that that's probably the
exception right not like a huge problem
i would imagine it's not a huge problem
i'm just fascinated that you can say i'm
a woman and going to california and
you're as a female prisoner as a man and
then they're doing some [ __ ]
and uh
uh in fact there there was one
a couple of accusations of rape so the
woman was like i got raped by this
transgender
woman
and then one of them got pregnant yeah
now the prison gets sued
it's all this stuff can you look that up
yeah i was like
because there's a there because i think
stephen crowder was talking about and he
got a strike from youtube yeah didn't
they take him down i think he got banned
he got a strike from youtube saying that
transgender men are dangerous could
could be a danger to some women in
female prisons and they were like you're
being and they said they pulled up oh he
got a strike for that oh wow and you
know because i guess does he have a step
but i'm sure he's not just no he's not
alpha stat
or just male and female female prison
but then they're doing stuff you're
saying right you're doing some fun if
you go to news go to news maybe
incarcerated intersex
uh well in custody at a men's prison in
california
anderson was ambushed brutally beaten
and sexually assaulted by several
princesses yeah if you are if you were a
woman and you are now identifying as a
man you go into a male prison that's
dangerous man those men will do some
[ __ ] oh yeah
wow
so nothing's popping up
may only make the women's prison there
you go yeah let's see
crazy in congress if cal if congress
passes the equality act california's
dangerous political california is
probably going worldwide
i've got to join to read the full
article so there is a policy
i think it is tough let's say you are uh
a transgender
male right and you feel female look at
this female
energy right yeah you're going to want
to be
you are
here's the thing it goes both ways so i
would imagine if you have a woman
you have a man a woman who it now
identifies as a man she gets put in a
man's prison you know what's going to
happen those guys are not that concerned
with gender transgender rights you can
have people they [ __ ] dudes in there oh
yeah yeah and now you have an actual
biological woman in there it's not safe
for that transgender person it's not
i would i think you would have your own
housing or you'd have to be in
protection you have to um thank god
thank god i don't have to make those
decisions look at this there are 1 274
people in california california prison
who have identified us as a transgender
or have something
yeah they they protect them they protect
housing gender people according to their
gender identity when safe to do so
increases safety yeah we have this idea
that a guy with a beard and a big dick
is now a guy i'm a girl put me in the
girl prison and then i don't think
that's happening i don't know they'd
probably do a background uh check out
what it seems yeah they're not gonna put
it man yeah six foot four we couldn't
roll up there and be like hey hey man i
mean
you know you have a lot of guys
literally just committing every guy oh
yeah i get to be on with a bunch of
women
you just be like what i'm just a little
little old me i guess we could all have
sex
i didn't get the surgery yet you know
what i'm saying i don't know
yeah it's kind of yeah
well this is what you run into it's very
it's very complicated it gets
complicated with the exception
everything's the exception
yeah it is it's a weird thing do you see
dave chappelle came out he finally
addressed the situation he goes i hear
you and he's like i'm i'm glad he's
glad to talk to them but he said uh on
his own i'm not bending the knee like
that's not happening
he's like in no instance will i back
down i love him yeah and he also said
like if you haven't watched his special
then he's not gonna talk to you
that's fair yeah you have nothing to say
yeah yeah
and then he was saying he he shot that
uh documentary that he's been airing a
lot of shows that now supposed to be at
all these film festivals all these
students supposed to pick it up and now
none of them will pick it up after his
transgender comments wait they won't no
no i feel like but he's releasing it in
like certain cities surprisingly netflix
isn't gonna be like hey we'll take it
you know
that sounds oh he did say something
about hannah gatsby too at the end i
she's talking [ __ ] to netflix but you
where was that same energy we took all
the money to put out your special and
then now you're not working with him now
you're going to [ __ ] on him
keep that same energy she's just not
that funny i'm sorry hannah guys no
i don't like her no i mean everybody's
like oh she's so amazing like make me
laugh she was supposed to be a comic she
she did ted talk yeah i saw that yeah
i'll watch it for myself yeah all right
but then there's no follow-up to that
now it's like and then [ __ ] she was just
i don't know you know what's funny with
this it'll be very interesting to see
how this pans out because
it's the business itself is about making
money and when you become the bottom
line when you become an activist and you
and you try to do this stuff and you
become
you know
you it's you will it's hard like ruby
rose she's that very hot lesbian who is
on orange is the new black
ruby and i guess she went bad oh she was
the she's she's the new batwoman yeah
well not anymore she got fired
but then she got but do you hear what
she did she got fired and she was like
the conditions were terrible they
treated me like [ __ ] every single person
came out was like it's the opposite
she's a complete piece of [ __ ] to work
with there you go and even water
brothers co-sign like what she's saying
is not true and now watch this now you
do that give me him over yeah you're not
working again there is no one that's
going to work with you you're crazy it's
a shame because she's obviously talented
but it's a shame she took the social
media and tried to [ __ ] get her way
and it ain't going to work and then when
water brothers the studio back she the
the people are saying she was a
nightmare they're like the only person
tough to work with was you on set and
all everybody on setco signed that yep
so once that game was just being an
[ __ ] it's such a shame that someone
had come up like hey you realize if you
if you go publicly this you're probably
not going to work this is big though
when when netflix sticks to their guns
and warner brothers says no i agree this
is big this is bear this is this is a
good thing for common sense for for
duplicates yeah i need to stop you can't
ruin people's life because you have a
twitter account yes and just because you
right now having a popular group that
people are sympathetic to that is a very
dangerous thing and so she's going to
get i think he claims toxic work
environment
she can die in that hill but you're just
not going to work in the business she's
not she's not going to work i think she
doesn't work anymore i guarantee she's
really tough
i've been with some people who make some
decisions recently and then it's not
going to happen
they're all like they're all like oh
yeah what happens like you know they go
like this in hollywood and it used to be
the brass that you didn't know about
it's like these guys and now it's the
same thing they just go like this they
just go okay cool yeah they just don't
it just gets quiet it just gets quiet
you know
it's just a lot of yeah
i've never forgotten talented people out
there in the world jeffrey tambour told
me one time he said and i've always
looked up to him as an actor and he said
your attitude monitors everything dude
and we were talking he goes he was
talking about somebody
who is
promising actor
doing a lot of work
and he got on [ __ ] set and he was
shouting about something and the
producer who was a big time producer
went like this just looked at the
director and went like this he goes
get rid of him
just like that i think it goes huh
and
guess what they did you know what they
did when they got rid of him what
they replaced him with another actor
super quickly it's like playing football
for alabama you drop the ball like right
bring in that guy you're not we don't
they're all good
yeah you you don't you know nobody's
here yeah
if you're brad pitt okay that's going to
be an issue but you know my brother
is easy to work with tom cruise is a
great guy to people yeah he was just mad
at that oh when you shout about the
covet stuff those people have good
reputations because they treat everybody
really well typically that's why they
last yeah
that's that's yeah going bad on people
like that we here too like i'm sure you
hear it too i always like to talk to the
managers about what nightmares they have
to deal with from comics
and then when you hear about it
especially for people and people we know
i'm like this doesn't end well man and
then you'll see sure enough two years
ago by like man he's not playing the
wilbur or whatever yeah no and they'll
be like we won't have them back this
career this career is a long one man and
it's always the same games too cool
everywhere we go everywhere we go it's
always the same i tell you about nothing
i just he does he asks every time every
time the man makes it who have you had
in here they'll mention some names i'm
like was and i'll say a name i'm like oh
my god yes they and then they just treat
them
talk to them yeah or they're telling me
they had this one comic headliner they
don't say his name terrible comic but he
would he wouldn't talk to anybody you
have to go through his uh assistant what
so even you'd be in the room and let's
say
you're let's say you're the manager
you'd ask me a question he would answer
to his assistant that would have to
get then you've got to relate to him
yeah
i don't get it why he does this
it's insane
they had another comic there the other
week who refuses to talk to white people
he's like our i mean we have like
something weird like that i think we
have three or four you know black people
on the staff but they're not no managers
so he's like i mean we can't
all right well i have to hand you the
check like we have to go through the
like what do you want me to do
no it was don't tip white people no
wasn't it that i thought it was that i
know who you're talking about because
i've heard no there there's there's a
there's a rumor i said who's the worst
comic to be in here and she said his
crowd never tips
oh i thought no matter what never and he
doesn't was something like don't uh two
different stories though two different
stories yeah okay
yeah one the one comic that tells this
that not to tell on stage says don't tip
the wait staff and then he also doesn't
tip the you know like people that sells
merch or take pictures yeah sounds like
a great guy
good comic that's the bummer
you know all these guys yeah i know i do
there's comics that won't let the
openers in the green room
yeah hilarious yeah
so weird i i just have a big problem
with all that so strange really catches
up with it they suck yeah it catches up
it's it's such a random thing yeah
what's an ego thing it's like dude it's
gonna kill [ __ ] are you gonna be an
[ __ ] yeah how about that's where
giving them a good shove around or a
slap around is a good idea yeah these
poor managers with these clubs you don't
have to deal with crazies oh yeah i was
in florida i couldn't do it when i was
headlining florida the guy i had hosting
he was like it's okay if i come in real
fast i asked you i was like i was like
it's a green room you know like come in
here and he was like oh you know you
know i know
comics don't really like uh headliners
don't like
you know the openers coming in i was
like dude i don't i was like i don't
care especially
in here no i don't like if they if that
opener brings in their brother and their
buddies and yeah or do you bring them
together guys you're a christian
people can't have that
because then it soaks your energy it's
also a liability yeah you just can't
have it yeah but if you're on the show
if we're on the same show
comics
we're going through the same thing of
course that is weird
[ __ ] all right jim what do you got
you know here's the thing when you have
a truck you're a truck guy i'm i'm a
truck guy you have a truck and i have a
bronco well i like you i could use and
and people like you talk about ride
height how it drives towing storage i
wanted to know i asked you how how's it
drive what kind of towing do you have
can you throw your dog in the back sure
problem is this time of year it's wet
it's raining even snowy in some parts
which means you left
you if you leave the back of your truck
like the hole's hunting you're you're
gonna sport something they're gonna
steal your whatever it is it gets ruined
that's waterproof
secures all my stuff
yeah you want to cover it and but what
are you going to do cover it in a damn
tarp that's what you did it was raining
and you had a nightmare you had half
your truck in a target covered in a
terrible tarp i didn't even know you had
a tarp that's hilarious you have to it
was just once in a while but it was a
lamest job you literally put it over
half your it was half over your trolley
half sticking out that's right you don't
cover the whole car it was so lame
either way i need deck dude
two full bed length drawers can carry up
to 200 pounds of whatever you got yeah
right deck drawer system keeps your gear
secure don't let people break in and
steal stuff from your truck they're bed
length drawers oh my god dex is 100 made
in the us of a backed by lifetime no
hassle warranty all right protect your
stuff like i do with deck get your deck
drawer system at deck dot com slash
fighter and get free shipping that's
deck dot com slash fighter for free
shipping on your deck drawer system
statement dot com slash fighter jack dot
com slash fighter and it locked up it's
very secure you cannot get into that
lock
dude you have to you know when you have
student loans uh this is the i know too
many people with student loans and
here's what you have to understand how
many friends are student loans you have
those loans you're in debt for the rest
of your life a lot of times but there
are so many people that that shouldn't
die
in debt tell them what he can do quickly
about your friends you can't claim
bankruptcy but if you if you want to pay
off your student loans faster yes listen
to this student debt
yeah you could potentially save
thousands with refinancing federal
student loan payments are on hold but
with the rates this low now is it time
to refinance
earnest for god's sakes look on uh
look earnest was one of the best student
loan refinancing overall by nerd wallet
earnest has some of the lowest rates
flexible payments an in-house team ready
to help with earnest you could change
your interest rate get a lower monthly
payment and you never pay fees not even
late fees by refinancing reduce your
loan term save money or combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment and
if you have questions you can even talk
to a live human i know that's crazy you
can talk to online human at earnest for
help yes with earnest it only takes two
minutes to see what your new rate could
be and there's no credit impact and
right now ernest is offering you guys a
hundred dollars cash bonus refinance
your student debt at earnest.com fighter
not available in all states once again
you get a hundred bucks casharoo bonus
when you visit earnest.com slash fighter
to refinance your student loan do that
one brad
visit earnest.com
for more details not available in all
states terms and conditions apply earn
student loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc n mls number one two oh
four nine one seven california financing
law license number six zero five four
seven eight eight five three five mish
mission street san francisco california
nine four one 105. wow visit harness.com
licenses wow for a full list of licenses
ernest.com slash fighter yeah
i want total human optimization i want
focus i want to be able to sleep well i
want digestive health i want daily
support i want essential nutrients i
want performance dude i want my immune
system to crush i have also protein dude
well i want protein i can trust with
listen listen if you've listened to this
show over the past freaking eight years
we've been harping to your ass to buy on
it if you haven't done it yet you're not
doing it right
dot com slash fighter 10 off whey
protein creatine protein bars coffee and
tea oh my god dude put some fat
bars warriors
brian i won't do it dude yeah get a
discount on fat butter put up your rum i
won't but i will do the on-demand
workouts 30 minutes decompressor defy
mobilize strength warm-up workout best
out best workout i've ever had word on
it best workouts oh yeah kettlebell
athlete you got morning mobility we've
got sandbags battle ropes we got it all
on it.com fighter 10 off
alrighty
there we go
so a hiker in colorado got lost on the
trail he left early in the morning and
later at night around 8 p.m the uh i
believe it was the park rangers uh they
realized that there was someone missing
who didn't come back so they actually
sent out a search party at 11 p.m trying
to find this man they searched for hours
and couldn't find them so they called it
off later on the very next day early in
the morning that guy i guess was
fumbling around at night trying to find
the trail finally he found it walked
back to his car and he said that he
wasn't aware people were looking for him
because he kept on declining calls that
he didn't recognize that robo killer the
guy have that with the spam the robot
you know he hasn't heard a robo killer
it blocks all like numbers you don't
know or like spam oh he says that he saw
the number the phone number come in but
he kept denying it because he thought it
was a spam number you gotta
and it was just a bunch of people trying
to find him when you're lost yeah you
gotta did he was he calling people no he
wasn't he sounds like a bro so
apparently he had enough reception to
receive phone calls he didn't use
anything on his phone to try to get him
back on this four hours a whole 24 hours
that's pretty snowy up there yeah well
being up there
has got to suck a dick
my buddy got stranded up on mount
whitney he climbed mount whitney and
well there's a tiny little you can
probably google it and there's a tiny
little shed
and no heat and uh
he was freezing to death like he so he
had to stand there at night he had hit
all his stuff on and he was having a run
in place and he couldn't stop just
placing yeah because he couldn't go down
he was too icy he had to rappel down so
he had to wait till the morning that is
your friend a professional climber yeah
he's a professional oh and he was and
the lightning's crazy up there too
that's the thing where's mount whitney
yeah but it's not it's really cold
because there's no heat so he's just
running up and down
look at that god damn it yeah
yeah he gets kind of it was like 30
below
running in place all night because he's
going to die not about that life what
else you got jen
this right here
so
2021 was the first year in two decades
where cigarette sales are actually
starting to increase and they're
contributing it to people being stressed
during independence oh sure and i love
cnn's like now we can't chalk this up
just to cove in the lockdowns like what
else would it be dummy
yes what else could it possibly be are
you [ __ ] depression how about
depression with kids how about all that
but how about but you know what else
it's through the roof alcohol sales
people
they're [ __ ] depressed weight gain
i guarantee that the covet lockdowns in
in the name of safety made so many
people
not only
really unhealthy but would lead to no
this major professional premature death
see florida has the lowest cases out of
any state now
it's weird i thought it was us
i did not see that
yeah
it's weird doesn't get picked up yeah
they did nothing
right and they're like well it's hot out
there shut up
[Laughter]
what else you got jen
so a instagram model went viral for
posting photos of herself next to her
father's open casket at his funeral god
damn
and shortly after this went viral she
actually deleted her entire account why
would she do that yeah i don't know
the first one uh
that was your thought to post for
instagram at your father's funeral are
you modeling morning apparel look at
that's your dad's funeral you're
dressing you're thinking more about
yourself yeah you're thinking about
yourself who's it who's this who's this
picture for
her followers oh [ __ ] to be fair one of
the posts i saw she got 11 000 likes on
one the poster she's somebody on
instagram yeah i know i guess yeah i
just don't know just wrestling piece
poppy yeah
this was okay a life we lived well a
life well lived i don't believe
i i don't buy it look at the hashtags
though hashtag veteran hashtag ptsd
hashtag funeral hashtag never forgotten
yeah you know if the dad was [ __ ]
awake right now like hey can you put
your tits away
do you mind not wearing that yeah she
looks really upset
it's a great outfit actually it's a
goddamn great outfit no i mean you wear
that scope oh
cool man but out of your father's dad's
funeral that's
and the poses the poses are just what
she's awkward she's just about herself
she's yes
she looks like a real narcissist super
shallow yeah i'm horrified the level of
shallowness yeah right here i mean
i mean read the room lady
dad died yeah forget about your
instagram and your tits for three
seconds
all right so barcelona
a college girl was at a party she
dropped her phone in the porta potty and
proceeds to reach into grabbing yeah
dude i haven't been in a porta potty in
a hot second do that tough mudder you
know what you're running yeah if you
have to be a stop and there's puerto
rico i went in there it's they're the
most the worst
the worst people have [ __ ] that much in
the morning i mean it's just an amount
of [ __ ] in like blue dye
i've seen and tiger has like bad reflex
like he was like yeah i'm like whoa get
out get out get up
yeah i've seen i've seen that uh break
apart and fall on a guy he got covered
in it um they lifted it up with a crane
you my friend again your friend
are very famous no no it was a tv show
it was a tv show about
people doing crazy things
but the guy said hey if you say friend
one more time guys like your friend who
climbs mountains no no it's not my
friend i saw it there's a guy there was
a there was a video of of a construction
worker and they're lifting it up with a
crane and it's just a smoke and it fell
all over dude what happened
it's disgusting it's the worst thing uh
when i was me and my homies were skating
at this uh college this is when we were
kids and uh there was a bunch of
construction going on and there was a
porta potty and i had to use the
restroom real bad and so i go in there
and as soon as i sat down
the dudes they dropped like an orange or
something in there and it splashed oh
all over me
i'm really squeamish about that oh yeah
it was it was the worst disgusting yeah
because there's like a little something
at the top that one falls over how about
you but i hate
i did this for world's dumbest
dude i would be so
and they're pretty easy to push oh
that's a man in a suit too
that was the foreman well there you go
just hose me down right now please no
just shoot me in the face like yeah
shoot me in the head like squid games if
i get going up your nose
covered in in just [ __ ] dude the one the
one stevo does because it's uh it's on a
bungee cord it's going oh yeah it's like
that shot uh right it'll make you throw
up dude and all he has on her
play this one all he has on is that
oh
just get a new phone
her friend's all gagging
how do you drop it
you found it
she found it
oh that's that like [ __ ] watch it
it looks like it some good old boys
dropped something it's definitely the
[ __ ] of all good old boys just a mixture
it's [ __ ] soup look how happy she is i
know
ah you found it
yeah yeah
[ __ ] that get into it i don't like
poo
even my own in that blue water too it's
just sitting there yeah and then someone
else shits on top of it yeah so it's
like this [ __ ] mountain yep ah
that works all right
a guy i was with a group of people i'm
just going to tell this story and he's
old nothing about it no better than he
goes you guys know what a shitler is
like we're all hanging around it's all
people who like we're all adults like
everybody's like kind of in the 40s you
guys know shitler is everybody goes we
look over and maybe you turn too much
money because when you [ __ ] and you go
everybody went like this everybody went
okay man
that wasn't a lot of [ __ ]
that's amazing
no he was joking but you know when you
try a joke and it's just out of place
yeah and and he went he went uh he goes
like this he goes
[Music]
i mean it might have worked in the 40s
in germany
i mean if you call hitler that makes
that's a good way to call him you know
[Music]
um
i don't know how good this stuff is but
so
this guy's an actor he's like a
very like a rookie actor and he said
that they're protecting
the camera but not the actual guys or
you know the you know the not so famous
actors on set
and then um that's the guy right there
they were saying he could be charged
with involuntary manslaughter but they
say that for a [ __ ] heaven yeah
and uh so i guess nicholas cage also was
upset with this girl the same girl that
was the armory person for the movie yeah
he said that she
like multiple times shot shotguns
without warning she's a super amateur
yeah
big in the business she had these jobs
yeah yeah she [ __ ] with my boy
nicholas cage
yep he looks crazy there he does look
really crazy there for sure
but she wouldn't warn people when she
would shoot rounds she would just do it
and he would say like you almost blew my
eardrums like let us know beforehand so
she has some sort of history this is
according to people on set not you know
too young to be an armored yeah she's
too young i don't want a young person
way too young
i don't know i've never met an armorer
in all my years who wasn't in their 50s
or 60s i mean i it's such an important
thing man
it's like his livestream when i did the
the tax collector because i had guns
there they were real ak-47s but they
weren't you know with real bullets yeah
but the people that control them were
[ __ ] former special forces like he
was like 50 but he was like
six tours in iraq or something yeah no
it doesn't mean that this girl this
doesn't mean this woman couldn't do
something she had her father was very
famous in the space she grew up around
it it
this is a very young person and yeah i i
think a lot of that has been overhead
yes and a lot of this is on probably the
production it's on yes yeah stunt
coordinator it's on everybody man it's
on the second a d
it's on the director it's
you know the stuff more than i'm sure i
do i've shot
you're giving it you just trust them but
well this is the other thing that
happens i've never had an experience
other than this when you're given the
gun as the actor
the armor will always show you
will always show you and the director
and the stunt coordinator that the the
the gun is
empty the chamber is empty or that
there's a fire in the hole if you're
shooting a live round chamber like you
said this story on monday but say
chamber yeah if you're if you have a
live
but the idea is
real [ __ ]
you had a real gun if you're gonna write
this [ __ ] down it makes no sense that
she had a christian you won't be an
actor right to [ __ ] that write it down
yep there you go bro yeah you worked at
a gun store but the old you had a real
gun on set is
makes no sense makes no sense
damn thing's moving again
but no so that actor even said that she
was she was under a lot of like pressure
even the apparently the director said
definitely don't have a real gun i know
so the director said like they're
rushing her so much that she was
actually doing a good job con
for them yeah they thought she was doing
a good job but
it's because the production was just so
fast yeah she couldn't get everything
handled brian tell us one more time how
to shoot a gun on that guy gotta shoot
get your [ __ ]
chamber one more time
chamber
chamber
do a lot of actors listen lock it and
load it yep
lock the camera off step away and then
don't you yell something like this one's
firing oh don't you say this gun's cold
um i've never heard gun cold but yeah
cold or hot cold or hot it's cold or hot
yeah cold out
okay this one's uh we only see a tiny
little clip of this but it looks like
from the video it almost seems as if
floyd mayweather is slightly homophobic
i'll just play the video you know i have
to get a picture because he had painted
nails yeah
that's just an excuse to not take a
picture yeah
the homophobe
he just doesn't want to take pictures
[Music]
[ __ ] off he just didn't want to take
away you guys saw that first bro floyd
doesn't want to take a photo of me
but are you a big fan of floyd [ __ ] i
question if he's even a fan of there's a
lot of questions right so yeah is floyd
just joking around yeah because he's so
he his team said he's in a rush he's not
taking pictures with anyone so i'm not
gonna take some pictures i can't you got
painted nails
okay i bet if his hair was colorblind
now you have pink hair
how many people have asked him ask him a
couple people to ask him to take
pictures yeah a couple couple
so yeah that made the headlines this kid
got his fame from it yeah i don't know
the kid's name but
i guess that's floyd's girl now
okay another one i saw this and i didn't
this is crazy okay go for it let's play
it for you this is [ __ ] nuts where's
he swimming at first of all florida no
this is like a
brazil yeah brazil you're right
oh oh
all that
that's a small alligator why didn't they
get on though because the alligator was
too small and didn't realize it probably
said oh that thing's too big for me
that's what a giant alligator would do
what's the video the video guy didn't
give a [ __ ] he's like you good [ __ ] yeah
does anyone here have any questions
about this video
you think it's fake i think it's fake i
think it's fake because it wouldn't bit
him on the show and he's just chilling
there right now i don't think it's fake
i think
i think it's
well the way it's just chilling because
they usually just take off after that
right yeah no i don't think so and the
way the speed of it too like it would
have got him on the leg though look
watch what doesn't touch his shoulder
and then he fasted look at this this
yeah it does
no it looks almost super real but that's
real dude these days huh but also their
bite
and don't they have the strongest bite
if they have an oldie they're one of the
strongest bites they have to be big that
thing that thing realized he was too big
to kill to roll so he just was like
that's a young alligator we'll find out
later if it's just it's a real video
here's the actual youtube video
he does the same one pretty much
the fact that this guy has this camera
already just perfectly placed at this
time yeah why is he
filming his home he just swims
look how fast this thing is yeah yeah
alligators are fastest when they're
hunting
but what about the ripples in the water
chin
no so i
you know i grew up with remote control
cars and stuff like that i'm pretty sure
you can make a remote control alligator
yeah like
yeah but that's a lot to open its mouth
remote control the servos see it look
let's see it again it does look real but
when i first saw it i was like oh my god
this is i'm crazy real but i don't know
okay
let's watch one more time mass like the
guy
it does seem like a lot to go through to
make a remote control alligator yeah
also he's even that disney
you can put fake blood on too yeah but
but okay so but where though when he's
in the water they're going to edit that
challenge
i could paint fake okay but he's in the
water watch this boom boom
and also when it's just sitting there
the guy the guy doesn't sound panicked
but now look now he gets out of the
water his friend doesn't say like oh
[ __ ] nothing he's just like
he's a little bit in shock yeah look at
him now
watch this
he's bleeding see his shoulder
looks pretty real cheddar
looks pretty real
he's lucky
hopefully some alligator experts will
let us know if alex
wow you can hear him speak in portuguese
yeah is that an alligator or a crocodile
what the [ __ ] is this alligator
hey look at this now dude it's an
alligator all day all right we shall see
that looks pretty real to me yeah me too
[ __ ]
i guess the part where it's just
chilling like that well that's why
because it's chilling so i'm like um
that makes sense it'd just be sitting
there kind of all relaxed i don't
[ __ ] know i see oh chin saying why is
his friend there filming um why aren't
they yeah it's perfect timing and all
that stuff but also i think it's real i
do too
she never believes in that stuff they're
doing construction oh i was like what
the hell's going on that was the video
playing okay
all righty
let's move on to
oh so this is also making some headlines
i don't watch love and hip hop does
anyone here know tammy rivera
baby mama waka flock is baby mama so
she's accusing this cvs employee of
being
of racial profiling the cvs employee
happens to be an asian woman
but i'll show you right here it's like a
bunch of different videos i'm in walker
cbs i come here almost every other night
i know every person that works in this
store
i came here to get some
uh satin hair wrapped and some do growth
oil
this lady sat here
she must be new she sat here and she
watched me on the owl acting like she
was fixing stuff in the aisle i'm
watching her watch me right
now i'm watching her i thought she know
she's watching me i opened the pack she
said becky becky she watched she's
watching me so hard that when i opened
this pack she said don't do that i said
who are you talking to no i said who you
talking you didn't say please i said who
are you talking to i said don't do that
i said i'm buying this i can do what i
want no you cannot don't do that i said
um you've been watching me this whole
pull the cameras back you did pull the
cameras back okay pull the cameras out
you thought you what you thought was i
was a child or someone stealing because
you said that you watched me in two
hours and i watched you watch me and i
didn't you're there for two hours not
one thing
oh
and i come here almost every other night
every employee who works here knows me
but her she must be new but she sat down
and watched me on the aisles shut up she
sat there and watched me on the aisles
and told me to not open and it was done
you opened up the
buy it in the store
she went on this real long title yeah so
she said it's racial profiling but
when you look at the comments on not her
page i think she deleted a lot of her
stuff you were like dude you're not
supposed to be opening of course yeah an
employee would look at you
yeah
[ __ ] in the store and then she was like
i have seven point something million
followers they're all seeing you right
now so she's you know
shaming this person
but then later on she sounds like a real
bully
what does she apologize for she said she
said no she still
stuck to her you know her original word
whatever but then she said like i don't
want her to be fired
because if she don't think cvs would
fire over there i don't know see it was
like so tell her not to open it i was
like hold on you have to fire the
employee that no matter what race you
are you open a package in the middle of
the aisle
she was curious you gotta you gotta look
right if someone's opening a package by
the way following somebody because a lot
of people steal [ __ ] from cvs a lot of
people yeah no matter whether you're
going there or not yeah if you're in
california by the way you can get away
with stealing up to a thousand dollars
worth of [ __ ] and nobody can do anything
to you so yeah
her she's doing her job i'm sure that
woman that asian woman is making
millions of dollars working at ces i'm
sure that's what she needs yeah that's
exactly what she needs to be you know
that was her kind of apologizing right
there she probably read the comments i
don't
but then i looked at her comments and
there wasn't that many anymore but
anyways she's young um she's actually
really like she's pretty sexy though
pretty thick pretty hot
yeah she's pretty attractive yeah yeah
she is oh damn that's her do you guys
recognize her now because i i've never
watched a show
you always get the one picture i don't
want to see that
there was a which one there was a bikini
there was a bikini one yeah there was a
bikini one chance
that one there or something which one in
the middle right the middle of her ass
for guys yeah yeah
everyone's saying different things
though top left top left whatever one
you like chin well you know
let's see what's going on she's kind of
yeah
anyways super tiny ways yeah
all up and down your timeline right
here
so i'm going to try it out myself
to see
how it is i'm about to buy one of these
because my bathroom
we're just walking around
that's crazy how the [ __ ] do you breathe
yeah it looks even it's not healthy oh
my god sometimes
she's got a tiny waist it's basically a
waist trainer yeah yeah
like old-school corsets right yeah it
[ __ ] up your organs
yeah that looks insane it doesn't seem
right
well she's to fight fine yeah what else
you got jen
she's cute
too bad she's kind of an anhole uh yeah
i mean she did try to apologize so you
know give her a break that'll even get
fired yeah
okay so i
have a badass was bad
jesus christ dude he's been he's
hardcore with this what the [ __ ]
world do you live in i know it's like oh
my god but it doesn't um all right so
this is what little nausea put out i
don't understand what it is exactly okay
go forward fill in the old man here so
little nasdaq the out and loud proud
sure probably loves them yeah so he's a
out and proud gay african-american uh
rapper huge huge super talented super
talented yeah so this uh boozy badass
he's an older like og like street comic
i'm sorry rapper doesn't
doesn't play comes from a different kind
of cloth does not play yeah but uh he
always like talks [ __ ] to little gnaws
about being gay so a little nas which i
think is funny was like oh i got a new
track coming out with boozy badass y'all
get ready and like because he knows
boozy can't stand them
now you'll see boozies [ __ ] remarks
you're like
oh yeah you're going to work anywhere
dude he went super hard he was canceled
terribly hard oh dude yeah he made a
video no no he hit a tweet but first
i'll play a little nausea because this
is like tongue-in-cheek it's not like
[ __ ] not bad what would that dog be so
i've been working on this song with a
little boosie bro
i had this song a little [ __ ] from the
come out
[ __ ] firing me family laughter
god damn sound little booty to come out
she's just being silly because that guy
hates him
okay so i don't know what this is oh
he's control right now okay
and then boozy was like excuse me this
is what he wrote i'm not gonna read it i
know but you can tell what he's saying
here stop trolling me the f word lol
a whole you know [ __ ] playing with a
gangster keeps shaking my head and dick
and getting
[ __ ] in your ass
and peace and
hate yourself yourself i would too if i
was you uh if you hashtag commit suicide
that's also what this world
[Music]
these people who just have to respond
this way yeah it's just unbelievable
that's pretty that's aggressive that's
hardcore how old is this he's older like
maybe in his 40s old enough to know
better then oh yeah this is why
instagram keeps taking down yeah
instagram keeps taking his account down
and everything he's young 38. he's
pretty young
he's not young that's old enough to know
better i'm saying like he's young enough
to understand this generation to not say
stupid [ __ ] he's kind of a gangster he's
got money yeah yeah
i don't know about money but i know i
know he's i know he's you know
he's he's pretty gangster shouldn't be
doing that though no that's just that's
[ __ ] hateful yeah no
that's not good yeah that's aggressive
why say he's little booze he had a
billionaire well that's just someone
asking yeah
i'll answer that for
you but you know elon musk yesterday
made thirty thirty seven billion dollars
it's the most anybody has ever made in
one day i think that's [ __ ] funny i
believe he's valued as a trillionaire
yeah he jumped over wow in one day
gave an order for a hundred thousand uh
rental cars yeah
anyways this is booty boozy badass's
response after all the backlash
if y'all think
if anyone cause there's audio listeners
too international for real for real
the realist yeah my buddy was in uh
philly and he told me that
all this politically correct stuff did
not get to the hood in philly he goes
all his friends are just using like all
kind at the f word and he's like whoa
whoa he's like man i've been in l.a a
long time yeah hollywood's a different
animal yeah holly was a different animal
but
is that it
um sure
unless you want some more stuff oh
what's greg abbott what's that about
okay the only reason i brought this up
is because i saw um
a headline
that says greg abbott signs
anti-trans bill
but his bill was more like he does he
wants transgender people to not you
like boys whatever gender you're born in
that's the score you'll play in
biological boys in
women's sports i think is like i don't
think that's being anything other than
commonsensical like what are you talking
about
so yeah but the same article that's that
said ruins
anti-trans bill it was the same article
when i clicked on it then it said oh
he's signing a building yeah
ridiculous a little clickbait for you
yeah yep
well
what can you do
that's it
that's it man
[ __ ] heavy all right my companion
this saturday fight companion saturday
brian cowan crystalia myself josh
thompson 11 a.m pacific start time live
on the thick boy youtube channel then
next week thursday friday i'm at the
haha los angeles ha ha november 4th and
5th and then november 11th through the
13th dallas texas addison improv get
your tickets at fatkz.com
uh brian callan will be at the
brea improv november 4. that's thursday
november 5 that's friday uh that'll be
two shows on friday and then november
6th i'm doing fight companion as well so
that's why i will not be doing stand up
on november 6. then we got uh naples
florida ladies and gentlemen november 11
12 13 14
off the hook comedy get your tickets
orlando florida coming in hot november
19th and 20th two sh four shows only
friday saturday number 19 20 orlando
florida improv
see you soon
all right november 17th tacoma comedy
club november 18th spokane comedy club
uh december 1st san jose improv and also
check out my podcast chapelle's world
yeah real quick real quick uh conspiracy
social club our hundredth episode
believe that 100 episodes uh conspiracy
social club aka deep waters aka highway
to the danger zone on rock family names
though you know yeah
sam rockfin rockfin dot com uh slash
conspiracy social club check it out
hi kids love you boom